[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We have a
great panel for you
today with women from
the cast and creatives
of "Beautiful," the Carole
King musical on Broadway.
Before she was Carole
King, superstar,
she was Carole Klein,
teenage songwriter.
For five years, "Beautiful,"
the Carole King musical
has thrilled theatergoers
with the inspiring true story
of one woman's remarkable
journey from teenage songwriter
to the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame.
From the string of
pop classics, she
wrote for the
biggest acts in music
to her own life-changing,
chart-busting success
with "Tapestry,"
"Beautiful" takes you
back to where it all
began, and takes you
on the ride of a lifetime,
featuring such unforgettable
classics as "You've Got
a Friend," "So Far Away,"
"Take Good Care of My Baby,"
"Will You Love Me Tomorrow,"
and "Natural Woman."
This Tony and Grammy
award-winning musical
phenomenon is filled with
songs you'll remember
and a story you'll never forget.
So we're going to kick it off
with a quick sizzle of Melissa
Benoist rehearsing
for "Beautiful."
And then we'll get
right into the Q&A.
[MUSIC - MELISSA BENOIST, "I
FEEL THE EARTH MOVE."]
[APPLAUSE]
MELISSA BENOIST: Sit here?
SPEAKER: All right.
Melissa.
MELISSA BENOIST: Hi.
SPEAKER: Everyone, let's welcome
our panelists, Melissa Benoist,
who plays Carole
King, Joyce Chittick,
our associate choreographer,
and Stacey Zaloga,
our assistant stage manager.
So Melissa, congratulations
on your Broadway debut playing
Carole King in "Beautiful."
I saw the show last week.
It was fantastic and great
to see your interpretation
of the character.
I had seen it prior as well.
And you currently
star in the title role
of "Supergirl" on
the CW, and you
starred in my personal
favorite, "Glee."
[LAUGHS]
Joyce, you are the
associate choreographer.
You've been on Broadway
for over 20 years
as a performer, a dance captain,
and associate choreographer.
Prior to "Beautiful," you
worked on "Anything Goes,"
"Grease," "Thoroughly
Modern Millie," "Cabaret,"
"Pajama Games," and "Cats."
And Stacey, you are the
assistant stage manager.
You've been with "Beautiful"
since the beginning--
so almost five years now.
And prior to that, you worked
on "Shrek, the Musical,"
and you've stage
managed other Broadway
and off-Broadway shows.
So our conversation
today is really
going to be focused on women,
women in the theater industry.
So each of you has had
very successful careers.
We're all thrilled to
have you here today.
So can you each tell us a
little bit about your careers
and how you came to
where you are today-- so
a bit about your career path.
And have there been women
who helped you along the way
in your careers?
MELISSA BENOIST: Well,
I feel a bit unqualified
to talk about being a woman
in the theater industry,
as I just made my Broadway
debut a month ago.
But I did grow up doing theater.
And it was my passion in life.
I started when I
was four years old,
and Broadway was
always the dream.
And I had many women
that really encouraged
me and helped me grow.
And each show I would
do, as I was growing up,
you become such a community and
a family in each production.
So yeah, I met a lot
of women along the way.
And one in particular.
I have a godmother who was
my dance teacher growing up,
who got to come see "Beautiful."
And she really ushered me
into this as a career choice.
SPEAKER: That's great.
Can you share your
career with us as well?
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
I began my career
in high school.
My senior year of high school
is when I joined "Cats," first
on tour, and then on Broadway.
SPEAKER: Wow.
How old were you?
JOYCE CHITTICK: I was 17.
SPEAKER: Wow.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I finished
high school on the road
by correspondence the
days before computers.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
That's how old I am.
So there was no laptop.
I hand wrote all of my papers.
And then I would save
them up, and then
I would put them in
a FedEx envelope,
and I'd send them to my teacher.
And my dad, I remember one
time, because it'd been a while
since I'd sent anything.
He wasn't sure that I
was doing my homework
because I was saving them up
to send them in one big FedEx.
And it was on that tour that
I met Kathleen Marshall, whom
I've done a lot of shows with.
And so as far as
women go, Kathleen
has been very instrumental in
giving me many opportunities
in this Broadway career.
And just like Melissa just said,
since the time I was little,
this was my dream, Broadway.
I remember seeing a Tony
Awards when I was, like,
seven or eight years old.
But that was the only
time you could watch it
because you couldn't rewind,
and you couldn't YouTube it.
And that image of
those Tony Awards
stuck with me till the next
year when they were on TV.
And it was always my dream goal.
SPEAKER: Stacey, can you tell
us about your career path?
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
I actually got into theater
and this whole aspect
of entertainment later
than most people.
It wasn't until college.
I was on a totally
different career path.
And my second year of
college is when I kind of
had my quarter-life
crisis and decided
to completely change
what I thought
I wanted to do my whole life.
SPEAKER: What was
your original plan?
STACEY ZALOGA: I thought
I was going to be pre-med.
And I was following my
dad's footsteps at that time
and wanted to be a doctor, or
so I thought, since I was nine.
And then I got to college.
And it wasn't going the way
I thought it was going to go.
And I decided to
take four classes
my second year of
college in anything
that I was remotely
interested in.
And an introductory to
theater class was one of them
because my parents had always
brought me to New York.
They're from New York
originally and would bring me in
to see Broadway shows.
And I fell in love with
it at an early age,
but I never, in a million
years, thought that I
would have a career in it.
So the introductory to
theater was just on a whim.
And I fell in love with it,
and ended up changing schools
and changing majors.
So by my third year college,
that's when I first started.
And I didn't even know
what a stage manager was.
I went to the
University of Kentucky.
And I went to the
theater department.
And they were like,
why are you here?
And I was like, well,
you know how you
watch the making of a movie?
I'm obsessed with that,
like, the behind the scenes,
whatever.
And one of my professors
said, on that very first day
when I met him, he said, you'd
be a great stage manager.
And I was like, what's that?
What is that?
SPEAKER: Do you want
to tell the group what
a stage manager does?
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
So as a stage manager--
well, for instance,
on "Beautiful"
there are three of us.
And basically, we
are there every day
to make sure that the
production basically happens.
One of us is on stage
left every day, one of us
is on stage right every
day, and the other one of us
calls the show.
And by calling the
show, that's basically,
we have a script of the entire
show with every light cue
and every scenic move
that happens in the show.
And any time the
lights change, it's
because we have said lights 36
go, and someone hits a button.
Any time scenery
moves, it's cause
we put a warn for a switch
in, and flick the switch off,
and someone takes the cue.
So in a way, it's kind
of like conducting
the lights and the scenery.
And we're also responsible for
watching backstage, making sure
everything's happening the
way it's supposed to happen
and maintaining the safety
of everyone in the show,
and helping to put new
people into the show,
and understudy rehearsals,
and maintaining
the production on a whole.
And we kind of communicate
with every department that's
involved in a production.
And our tasks vary from
beginning a show, rehearsals,
through tech, through
actually running of the show.
But we're there every
single day doing that.
So yeah.
So when my professor
told me, you'd
make a great stage
manager, I didn't
know any of this, of course.
And I had to learn, in
college, what it was.
And they just kind of threw me
on some main stage productions.
And it just was
so natural to me.
And we didn't actually have a
stage management class there.
So I just was guided
by my professors.
And especially, with
women, there was the chair
of our department at the time,
[? Gerri ?] [? Maschio, ?] who
was probably the most important
woman in my life as far
as my career goes.
She really guided me along that
process and helped me a lot.
So she's probably the
most instrumental woman.
SPEAKER: That's really great.
I think we all--
especially as women,
in our careers,
our mentors and our
sponsors are really
pivotal in helping us
find our career path
and taking that next step.
So coming back to the
show, "Beautiful,"
it is centered on one
woman's story and career.
So can you tell
me how each of you
feel connected to Carole King's
story and her body of work?
MELISSA BENOIST: Hm.
[CHUCKLING]
JOYCE CHITTICK:
Well, I'll start.
Unlike Stacey, I wasn't here
from the very beginning.
I came in when we began
the national tour.
And I've since gone on and put
together "The Japan Company."
And now you said
Tony and Grammy,
it's now also a
Helpmann Award winner.
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
In Australia.
JOYCE CHITTICK: So
just the other day--
yes, five Tony awards,
including Best Musical.
So I was there.
I helped Marc Bruni put together
the production in Australia.
So I came on board.
And I came to see the show
before I met the choreographer.
And I came by myself, which
I was really glad I did.
And I just wept.
And the first time that my
heart strings were pulled
was when Carole first
sings "Wonderful."
And I'm a mother now.
And having lived
your life a lot--
relationships, et cetera,
marriage, children, et cetera--
there was so much
that spoke to me
and so many songs
in the show that I
didn't realize that she wrote.
And they are timeless.
And I still, three years
later, watch the show,
and I get teary eyed moments
because it's just human nature,
you know what I mean?
And there's so
much joy and heart.
And it speaks to everybody.
It really does.
And I was just
instantly drawn to it.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
I had a very similar experience
watching it for the first time.
I hadn't seen it until I knew
I was going to be doing it.
So I watched it
for the first time
the night before I
started rehearsing.
And I just gave myself
one night to let
it kind of wash all over me.
And I, essentially, like
washed myself with my tears.
[LAUGHTER]
I was crying.
I was weeping.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
And in a good way too.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yes.
JOYCE CHITTICK: At the end, like
in such a joyful way, the lyric
that you get to
sing every night,
"you've got to wake
up every morning
with a smile on your
face and show the world
all the love in your heart."
And in our world today, I
think that that sentence just
speaks volumes.
And that's what we
need in our lives is
to show people the love
that we have and the care.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
And that's really what is
so beautiful about Carole,
and why she is
this living legend.
Because she lives that way.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
Have you met her?
MELISSA BENOIST: She
really does-- no.
I haven't.
SPEAKER: Have you met her?
STACEY ZALOGA: I've met
her several times now.
Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I've met her.
And she is full of life.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: She has more
energy, I think, than all of us
right here put together.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
She does.
STACEY ZALOGA:
She's exactly what
you want her to be and more.
And the expectations of what you
think she's going to be, like--
JOYCE CHITTICK: It's no wonder
these melodies came from her.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: They
just emanate from her.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And so did any
of you know her music
or love her music
before the show?
STACEY ZALOGA: Oh, of course.
Yeah.
Yeah, the "Tapestry" album,
probably for all of us
was my mom's favorite
album of all time.
And it became one of
mine, as a child too,
because my mom loved it so much.
And I remember on road trips,
we'd have our CD collection.
And what do we listen to now?
And I would always be like,
Carole King time, let's go.
Let's put "Tapestry" on.
So it was very
special to me too.
And I remember when I got this
job too, and I was so excited,
and I told my mom
all about the show.
But I didn't tell her
what it was first.
And she was so excited.
Then I go, do you want
to know what it's called?
And she goes, yeah.
And I go, "Beautiful,
the Carole King Musical,"
and she just freaked out.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Did your mom
get to meet Carole?
STACEY ZALOGA: My mom
actually has met Carole.
When Carole did "The
Today Show" with us
once with Chilina and Abby right
before Abby went out on tour,
my mom happened to be
visiting me in the city.
And I wasn't supposed to
go to that press event.
Other people were going.
And I was, like, I don't know,
do you want to roll out of bed
and go over there?
And she was like,
if I don't, I'll
regret it for the
rest of my life.
So we did, and we went.
And I got to introduce Carole
to my mom really quickly.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Carole needs
to get here before you go.
MELISSA BENOIST: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
I hope I get to meet her.
I don't want to know if she's
in the audience until after.
But I hope to meet her.
[LAUGHTER]
JOYCE CHITTICK: It's a
little bit of pressure.
STACEY ZALOGA: That's
a lot of pressure.
SPEAKER: Joyce, can you
tell us about your role
as associate choreographer
and what that entails?
JOYCE CHITTICK: So I
maintain all the movement
in the show for the Broadway
company and the national tour.
So it involves various things--
auditions, finding,
helping the casting people,
find people that are
right for the show,
teaching them the movement,
working with them.
When we hire people,
I'm the person
that initially works
with them and teaches
them all the movement.
And when I say,
"teach the movement,"
we're working with people
that are not dancers first.
They're singers.
This is a singer's show.
And so a lot of
times we have found
people that are phenomenal
talents, that their voices are
incredible, but they're not
confident in their movement.
And so I come in
and I help them find
that confidence and their
natural movement abilities
and sort of help show them
that it's not about five,
six, seven, eight.
It's about the feeling
of the movement,
and where it comes
from within you.
So that's sort of my main goal.
And to keep it fresh--
like I said, because we're
now how many years running?
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
4 and 1/2 I guess now, yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I'm not
about, here's the steps,
and you have to do
it just like this.
Sometimes I'll not
change the choreography,
but just find how it
works on their bodies
and keeping it exciting and
passionate from each performer.
SPEAKER: And Joyce,
is this very different
than other shows you've
worked on that maybe,
if this is more of a singer's
show than a dancer's show,
has your approach had to be very
different than on other shows
that are more dance-oriented?
JOYCE CHITTICK: Very different.
And you say my 20-plus career--
I began dance captaining
when I was 20,
with "Tommy" on Broadway.
And throughout my
course of my career,
I have worked with so many
different abilities, and ages,
and body types.
And you have to
find each person.
What's going to
work for one person
doesn't work for another.
And your approach is different
with singers than it is
for somebody who has spent a
lot of time in front of a mirror
learning how to plié
and hold their arms.
And when I do have people
that come into the show that
have had a lot of
dance training,
it's a completely
different approach
of how you work with
them versus the singers.
In Australia and
Japan, for example,
I had a couple guys that had
never done musical theater.
One was, like, a gospel singer,
and the other, in Australia,
he was this Jazz singer.
And they're comfortable
singing, but yet, as soon
as you teach them
choreography, this fear of God
comes over them.
And so it's taking that
fear away from them
and getting them to realize that
what we're doing is so simple.
And you do it when you're
fooling around in your shower,
you know what I mean?
But then when suddenly it's
those five, six, seven,
eight come out of a mouth,
everybody goes like this.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: So each of you
shared that Broadway
was a dream of yours.
It was a consistent
theme for each of you.
So can you share how each of
you began your Broadway journey
and how you came to
work with "Beautiful?"
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
It's weird because I feel
like, in this business,
a lot of the jobs that I've
gotten, 90% of the time
has been because
of the job prior,
because I knew somebody that
led me to somebody else.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I was there
for Stacy's first job.
STACEY ZALOGA: That's true.
We met 15 years ago on a
production of "The Boyfriend"
that Julie Andrews--
it was her directorial debut
out at Bay Street Theater
out on Long Island.
And I was an intern then.
But Bay Street used interns as
the assistant stage managers.
So even though I hadn't
joined the union yet,
I still was the assistant stage
manager on that production.
SPEAKER: Was it an
unpaid internship?
STACEY ZALOGA: It
was paid, but "paid."
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Housing.
STACEY ZALOGA: Grunt money,
housing, they give you housing.
That was like a
very small, $100--
I don't even remember--
maybe $200 at most a week,
or maybe not even that.
But that's what a lot of
production assistant and intern
jobs are at first until you
actually do get into the union
and get union jobs.
So my career kind of
took off after that
show because the scenic
and costume designer was
Tony Walton who used to be
married to Julie Andrews years
ago.
And they had a daughter Emma
who actually, at the time,
was running Bay Street Theater.
And I started working
for him after that
as a personal assistant
for a little while.
But one of the questions
he asked me was,
what do you really want to do?
And I said, I really want
to be a stage manager.
And he said, I think I
can help you with that.
So he introduced me to
an amazing stage manager
named Peter Lawrence who got me
my first sub job on "Spamalot,"
and then my first full
time show, which was "Shrek
the Musical," and then things
just kind of progressed
from there.
But this job is actually
different in that I reached out
to our production stage
manager, Peter Hanson.
And I just, on a whim, started
reaching out to some people,
just saying, hey, can
I have coffee with you?
And he met me for coffee.
And then a year later,
he hired me to work
on a workshop production.
And then another year
later, this job came up,
and he just called
me out of the blue.
And that had gone so well that
he asked me to do this with him
and Johnny [? Kraus, ?]
his assistant.
And they've been working
together for years.
So yeah, Peter and Johnny
have been working together
for 20-plus years together.
And I was new to their
team and got to join them.
And the three of us just
worked so well together.
So it was kind of a perfect fit.
SPEAKER: And how'd you
come to "Beautiful?"
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
Because I had worked with them
on a prior two-week-long thing,
and Johnny really liked
me from that moment,
when they were looking
for an assistant,
they really wanted to
have a woman, actually,
as their third team member
just because, A, they
like working with
women, and they also
just like having the team
kind of be balanced that way.
So Peter always says, sometimes
other women in the show
like to talk to women.
And so it's kind of nice to have
the team have a variety of men
and women and stuff.
So yeah, and then we just
started working on the show
together.
And it was my first time working
with them on beginning a show.
I mean, they had worked
together for years.
But I had just joined in.
So trying to find
the balance of how
I fit in this team
with the two of them.
And it just worked really well,
and we all get along so well.
That's why all three
of us are still there
because we enjoy
working together.
JOYCE CHITTICK: That's rare.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah,
it's very rare actually.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: And Joyce, you
started your career at 17.
JOYCE CHITTICK: At 17.
And then that led me to the
Broadway company of "Cats."
And as I mentioned
earlier, Kathleen Marshall
was one of the dance
captains on tour with "Cats,"
and she taught me the show.
So that friendship began there.
And when I moved to
New York to do "Cats,"
I pounded the pavement
the old fashioned way,
picking up a paper backstage.
I didn't have an agent.
I went to those open calls.
And you would go check
your answering service.
Mine was Bells are Ringing.
And I think my box
number was, like, 312.
And you'd go to a
payphone, and you'd
see if you had a callback.
And one thing led to
another, and I just
kept working going
from show to show
and became a dance captain
very early on, like I said,
with "Tommy."
And that sort of led
a parallel career.
I was a career as a
performer, but then I
was always sort of juggling
this other side of myself
as a dance captain.
And Marc Bruni and I
have known each other--
my gosh, how long now--
over a decade.
We've done several
shows together
when he was an associate.
And I did at production at
Encore of "Paint Your Wagon."
I was the associate
for Dennis Jones.
And they were
looking for somebody
in this position
for "Beautiful."
And Marc recommended me to
the choreographer, since Marc
and I had worked together in
"Grease," and other shows,
putting people into
shows and stuff.
So that's how I
came to "Beautiful."
SPEAKER: People
looking out for you.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: And Melissa,
how about you?
Can you tell us about
your career path,
how you started your
career, and how you
came to work on "Beautiful?"
MELISSA BENOIST: Well,
I knew, like I said,
Broadway was my dream.
So I came to New York City to
go to college on the Upper East
Side at Marymount
Manhattan College
to get a degree in acting.
And Broadway and
the stage was kind
of the only arena I thought
I was going to pursue.
And then I started
doing episodic work
because almost every actor,
at one point or another,
gets an episode of
"Law and Order."
[LAUGHTER]
It's inevitable.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
You've made it.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
Or more multiple.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
I've done two.
I did "SVU" and an episode
of "Criminal Intent"
before that show
went off the air.
But I really enjoyed
how different it was.
And so that's sort of where my
path into television and film
started.
And that was really
unexpected and really did
kind of take me away
from theater for a bit.
But I was doing the same--
pounding the pavement
and going to open
calls and running
and having three auditions a day
and not really getting anywhere
in theater and doing a few
regional things here and there.
And then I got "Glee," which
I was very fortunate to do
and kind of involved my
love of musical theater.
But it took me to the
opposite side of the country.
And then things kind of
snowballed after that.
But I was always wanting to come
back to stage and to New York
because I just love
being in this city.
And I feel like myself on stage.
So I was constantly pestering
my agents and my managers,
like, guys, I really
want to do theater.
And they'd be like,
yeah, yeah, OK, OK.
And then this kind of came
about because Chilina Kennedy,
she got a show at the
Atlantic Theater Company,
and they needed someone in
the interim for two months
before Abby Mueller came back.
And it sort of just fit
into this tiny little slot
on my hiatus of
"Supergirl." and?
I was planning on doing nothing.
SPEAKER: Your summer vacation
is working eight shows a week.
[LAUGHTER]
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
It did.
And I couldn't be
happier that it did.
I wouldn't have
forgiven myself if I
didn't take this opportunity.
And it's sort of like
a dream come true.
And I'm turning 30 this year.
And my childhood dream,
cheesily, came true this year.
SPEAKER: Aw.
[LAUGHTER]
STACEY ZALOGA: We've had
a lot of Broadway debuts
on our show too.
It's fantastic.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
STACEY ZALOGA: It's fantastic.
The energy when that happens--
and Melissa joined and so
many other people that have--
JOYCE CHITTICK: A lot of
our drifters and Shirelles.
STACEY ZALOGA: --had their
Broadway debuts on our show.
We just added another,
Shirelle just recently
that she also joined the
union and Broadway debut.
MELISSA BENOIST: She got
her actor's equity card?
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah, she did.
MELISSA BENOIST:
Oh, that's awesome.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
And the other day
when we were working on
the stage for the first day
on stage, she said,
oh, a thing came up,
a memory on my Facebook.
Seven years ago, I was
doing an internship,
and I was making $50 a week.
MELISSA BENOIST: Oh.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
And now, here she
was, standing on her
Broadway debut stage.
MELISSA BENOIST: That's amazing.
STACEY ZALOGA: That makes it
so fun when that happens too.
SPEAKER: Melissa,
can you tell us
about stage acting
and screen acting,
and what the
differences are, and how
you approach each of them?
And does working on both
help you hone your craft?
MELISSA BENOIST: They're so
different to the point where
I hadn't been on stage in
almost six years before I
got this opportunity.
And I would be in
rehearsals with Shelley,
one of our associate directors.
And she'd be like,
I think you just
need to speak up a little more.
And I'd be like, oh, sorry.
I have to get back into this.
There are totally different
skill sets and muscles
that you have to flex.
And it's hard.
It's a different way of
conveying your emotions.
It's a different scale of
energy that you expend.
And it also depends
on whatever project
you're working on because,
working on "Glee,"
I could be a little more
theatrical and presentational.
But then, things
like, I've worked
on the movie, "Whiplash."
And that had to be so
subtle that I almost didn't
feel like I was doing anything.
You just kind of
had to feel and hope
that it was translating somehow.
And I don't prefer
one or the other.
They're both challenging
in their own respect.
But yeah, it's a really
different approach.
SPEAKER: Do you hope to
continue spending your summers
on the stage in some capacity?
MELISSA BENOIST: Oh,
my gosh, of course.
Yes.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Are
you going to come back?
MELISSA BENOIST: I hope so.
I would love to.
SPEAKER: So can you
all tell us what
has been the most surprising
thing about working
on Broadway?
So each of you has dreamed
about this since you were young.
Are there things that are
different than you expected?
JOYCE CHITTICK: Well,
when you're little,
and you don't realize that
it's eight shows a week.
MELISSA BENOIST: I was just
going to say the same thing.
Yeah, eight shows
is a big number.
JOYCE CHITTICK: It's
eight shows a week,
week, after week, after week.
But then, to remember that the
audience, maybe there are fans,
and they come and see it a lot.
But the audience is seeing
it for the first time.
And you've got to make
it fresh every time.
And so you've got to find
that passion within you
every night to not just phone
it in, not just press autopilot.
And I know, for myself, with
all the shows that I have done,
I would sort of hit a
year mark with a show.
And I would be like, I can't
do this eight times a week
anymore, week after week.
But I also was always teaching
the shows most of the time.
I was, not only
physically performing it,
but I was always teaching
one track or another.
And keeping it fresh,
it's a hard thing
to do week after week.
And being a dancer, what
it has done to my body,
you know what I mean-- like
the aches and the pains
from doing that
repetitive motion.
MELISSA BENOIST: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER: Stacey, how about you?
What surprised you?
STACEY ZALOGA: I
would second the time
commitment that it takes.
And I think the hardest
part for everyone,
and it's something that
we all talk about a lot
backstage is the
fact that we miss out
on a lot of other
family life events.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Holidays.
STACEY ZALOGA: In
order to do this.
Holidays, we work holidays.
Everyone's normal weekend,
generally, is Friday to Sunday,
and that's our busiest time.
We generally do five shows.
I've missed weddings,
friends' weddings and events.
And we get occasional time
off, but it's limited,
and it's hard.
Especially, the
holidays are hard.
And to have our families
understand why sometimes, I
can't make it to that.
I really wish I
could, but I can't.
That's probably the
hardest part of the job.
But it's so rewarding too.
I find, when I do talk to
family and friends outside,
they just want to ask me so
many questions about, oh, what
do you do?
That must be so cool.
And I find myself, the day to
day sometimes is exhausting.
But I do have moments
backstage all the time
where I'm like, this is so cool
that I do this for a living.
Like, this is my job.
Like, they pay us.
I had a surreal moment the other
day when one of our hair people
was walking around with
like wigs on heads,
I was, like, this is our day.
This is our life.
We get paid to come
here and do this.
And our building has been
such a special family feeling.
Everybody that comes in is just
another member of the family.
And it's been such a
happy place to work.
MELISSA BENOIST: It's
a very good group.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Very good.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
They're going to have to drag
me out of that building one day,
because I'm not leaving
until they make me.
SPEAKER: And having worked on
so many different shows, this
is just one you
just don't tire of.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: You don't
tire of this music.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
The music never gets old, ever.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
And the joy of it.
I've been a part of shows that
you don't have that experience
every night.
And you're battling
to stay running,
and you're like, oh, the
audience weren't there.
They didn't like it.
They weren't engaged in it.
But this is one of those
shows that you just
take people on a journey,
and it's a joyful one.
MELISSA BENOIST: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER: Melissa,
how about for you?
So one month in on Broadway.
It's still fresh for you.
What's been most surprising?
MELISSA BENOIST:
Well, I think what's
been surprising is very similar
to what Joyce was saying.
Because I was coming into this
like, oh, eight shows a week,
yeah, It's a lot.
But I'm used to working 16
hour days on "Supergirl"
and being in a spandex
suit and a leather cape
for 15 of those hours.
SPEAKER: Under hot lights.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
And that's an exhausting
job, and it really
takes a lot out of me.
But-- so I think
I underestimated.
I underestimated it.
And this is the difference too
between television and stage
acting is the audience.
There's nothing like that.
And it is kind of
stereotypical to say,
but it changes everything.
And it requires so much
more focus and energy.
And you really have to mean
it because they can see it.
JOYCE CHITTICK: And you
take a journey every night.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: You
ride that full arc.
MELISSA BENOIST: You have
to go there with them.
And it's more exhausting to me
than "Supergirl" has ever been
and in a very fulfilling way.
So that is something
that's been surprising to
me is the time commitment
and how much of my soul
I bear every night.
JOYCE CHITTICK: And even
though you're exhausted,
when you receive that
love from the audience,
you probably-- it takes a few
hours to go to bed at night,
right?
MELISSA BENOIST: Oh, my gosh.
I'm wired.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
You're on a high.
Even though you're
exhausted, you're on a high.
MELISSA BENOIST: I am
starving, and I'm--
I can't sleep.
JOYCE CHITTICK: But
you're exhausted.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yes.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
It's the best drug.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yes.
Totally.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Seriously.
STACEY ZALOGA: I mean, I still
get goosebumps every night
during the curtain
call, especially when
whoever's playing
Carole comes out,
and that audience just
goes crazy every night.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So over the past few
years, representation
in Broadway, theater has become
more important than ever.
And this includes
bringing more women
into the spotlight, as well as
more women behind the scenes.
So we're seeing more
and more opportunities
for women in the industry.
So what have you been noticing,
from your perspectives,
as members of the theater
community and the TV community?
And are you seeing more
of this positive change?
STACEY ZALOGA: Definitely.
I've talked to Peter and
Johnny, the stage managers
that I work with, and
they say, 15 years ago, it
was all a male-dominated field,
stage management, generally.
And he goes and teaches
a lot to classrooms
and is seeing now,
in the colleges,
the stage management
groups, he says, are now,
it's almost all women in the
classrooms and very few men
now.
And I definitely
feel like there's
been a shift, especially
in my department
over the last 15 or so years.
MELISSA BENOIST:
That's exciting.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah,
it's really cool.
SPEAKER: That's
great, especially
for the more technical
side of theater.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
Because there aren't a lot.
And even on our show, we now
have a sound person woman,
Kate.
And Josie's backstage,
and there's more women.
But especially the crew is
definitely more male-dominated,
but definitely, we're starting
to infiltrate a little bit.
[GIGGLING]
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And here at Google,
we're very invested
in getting women more involved
in the technical side,
and investing in
girls, and helping
them learn to code as well.
So it's great to
see that there's
a similar shift happening on
the technical side of theater
as well.
Is there any advice
that you would
like to give women or
girls who aspire to be
part of the theater community?
STACEY ZALOGA: Oh, goodness.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I mean,
it's a different day and age
now from when I began.
I mean, this social media--
I mean, here we are in Google.
Social media is
just everything now.
But I think that's great, and
I think it's a great tool.
But I think that
there's nothing like
the good old fashioned hard
work of taking those classes.
And not just, oh, yeah, my video
looks great, don't I look good?
But no, can you do that
eight times a week?
Can you sustain that?
And if this is what you want to
do, it has to be your passion.
STACEY ZALOGA: Mm-hmm.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: You
have to love it.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
It's too hard otherwise.
JOYCE CHITTICK: It is
an emotional roller
coaster at times.
STACEY ZALOGA: It really is.
Never knowing when your
next job is going to come,
how long it's going to last.
It's a grind.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yes.
It is a grind.
But if you love something,
then invest everything
you have in yourself to do it.
And the people along the
way that you may think
may not mean anything
sometimes, those
are going to be the people that
will call you up and say, OK,
or recommend you.
And I would never have
thought I'd be here,
but it was my relationship with
Marc Bruni that led me here.
I didn't know the
choreographer before this job.
MELISSA BENOIST: That's
kind of what I would think
is advice that I would
have liked to have heard.
I think the more you
give, as a person,
it's returned to
you in abundance,
especially with kindness,
and especially with listening
and taking the time to get to
know the people you work with
and sharing the experience
and really remaining present
and being where you
are in that moment.
And you're right.
It pays off.
And it's always in the
most unexpected ways.
And also, I think this show
kind of exemplifies that too.
Because we take this
journey every night,
and with Carole kind of finding
ownership of who she is,
and really embracing
herself as an artist.
And I think, if you want
to do this as a career,
you really have to find
that inner light in yourself
to follow it and to really
just be true to who you are.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So this has been a really
challenging and eye-opening
year for women in the
entertainment industry
with the Me Too and the
Time's Up movements.
Scores of women have spoken
out about sexual assault
and harassment in the
entertainment industry.
And through the Times
Up movement, there's
been a focus on
workplace equality
and creating economic
opportunities
and fair pay for women.
So what have your
experiences been, as women,
during this watershed moment
in the entertainment industry?
And have you or other women
you know or have worked
with overcome challenges?
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's ongoing.
I do have to say, though,
joining this company,
I've not felt anything,
but just warmth and love.
And this particular company,
from what I've seen,
you guys have it figured out.
And everyone is just on
the same playing field.
That's what I've experienced.
It's been a stressful
year and a frustrating one
in many respects concerning
Time's Up and Me Too,
but also very uplifting.
And specifically,
on "Supergirl,"
I do see things
changing every day.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MELISSA BENOIST: And it's a
male-dominated field, the crew,
for a television series,
but we're hiring more women.
And we're trying to get
more female directors.
And it's always a part of
the conversation, every day,
that we're putting
something out there.
We're like, OK, well,
what are we saying?
And what does this
have to relate to?
How will women and young
girls, specifically,
take this and internalize it?
And how will this
make them feel?
And what are we saying and
adding to the conversation?
A day does not go
by that I don't
think about what's happening.
SPEAKER: Especially
portraying a character
that girls are looking up to.
So are you thinking about
things like the writing,
and what is your
role portraying?
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah,
absolutely, and making sure
that women believe that they
can have parity and equality.
And we call ourselves more
humanist than we are feminist
because we are
feminists as well,
but humanists-- we just think
everyone deserves to be equal,
no matter what
sexuality, no matter
what gender, no matter where you
come from, your race, anything.
So yeah, it is definitely a
part of our conversations.
SPEAKER: Great.
At this point, we'd
like to welcome people
to come up to the microphones,
if you have any questions,
So feel free to
come up to the mics.
And I'll continue with
questions as well.
Melissa, you are involved
in a mental health awareness
movement called IDON'TMIND.
That works to put a stop to the
stigma around mental illnesses.
How did you come to be involved
in IDON'TMIND, and what are you
hoping to achieve?
MELISSA BENOIST: Well,
my boyfriend, Chris Wood,
he has had the idea to start
this for the past five years
because he, sadly, lost his
father due to mental illness.
So it's very near and
dear to his heart.
It means a lot to
him because I think
he felt things might have gone
differently if there wasn't
such a stigma around dealing
with it or getting people help
or talking about it.
And he grew up in the Midwest.
So I think it is different
in many different places.
So he wanted to start it.
And I think everyone
in this room,
maybe, either knows someone
or experience it yourself,
and none of us are immune to it.
Our brains are very delicate,
and fragile, and complicated
things.
And we both, Chris
and I, believe
that you should
take care of them
the way you take care of
the rest of your body,
the way you go to a gym to
take care of your health,
you should go to a
therapist or a counselor
to take care of your mind.
And it's not a shameful thing.
So I've been really involved
in helping him come up
with who we want to target--
young people--
but anyone really.
And just get people
talking about the way they
feel with each other and being
open to listen and be there
when someone needs
a helping hand.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And opening the dialogue.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
Absolutely.
SPEAKER: Great.
Let's take a question here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you all for coming.
This question's for Melissa.
I was wondering, as you
were preparing for this role
to play Carole
King, how much did
you prepare to sing in your
own voice versus impersonating
Carole King's voice?
MELISSA BENOIST: Well, I
met with our music director,
Jason Howland, a couple of weeks
before I got into rehearsals
just to sing through the music
and to learn some of the piano
bits.
And the first
thing he said to me
was, we don't want this
to be an impersonation.
It's not you mimicking her.
It's not any of that.
But listen to her music.
Don't listen to Jessie Mueller.
Don't listen to
Chilina's versions.
Listen to Carole, and just
try to infuse just her aura,
if you can.
So that's all I did,
really, was I would just
listen nonstop on
repeat to "Tapestry,"
and her versions of the
songs that I was singing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER: And Melissa, you
played piano before the show?
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah, I do.
I cannot play like Carole,
but I did play piano, yeah.
SPEAKER: So was that
challenging to learn
to play piano as Carole
on the stage as part
of the rehearsal process?
MELISSA BENOIST: Yes.
Essentially, it was the
thing I was the most nervous
about from the get-go.
But it's a bit
like choreography.
JOYCE CHITTICK: It is.
Yeah.
MELISSA BENOIST: It's a
different part of your brain
you have to--
But now, you get
in the rhythm of it
with the song when
you're singing on stage,
and it's a lot of fun.
SPEAKER: And so, Melissa,
you'll be in the show
through August 4.
What is next for you?
So you'll be returning
to "Supergirl."
MELISSA BENOIST: Yes.
I think I have two
days in between.
I close "Beautiful,"
I have a weekend,
and then I'm back in Vancouver
shooting two days after.
SPEAKER: And what do
you hope to do next?
MELISSA BENOIST: I don't know.
We're up in Canada
for quite some time.
It's like 10 months
out of the year.
SPEAKER: But now you've
got this theater itch.
MELISSA BENOIST: I don't know.
Take it a day at a time.
I would love to
get back on stage.
I'm always going to be looking
for more theater opportunities.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And Joyce and Stacey,
how about you?
Stacey, you've been with
the show for five years.
STACEY ZALOGA: Yeah.
I'm hoping it'll be five more.
So I'll be there.
I'll be there.
SPEAKER: So you're hoping
to stick with this.
STACEY ZALOGA: As
long as-- yeah.
SPEAKER: And Joyce, for you?
JOYCE CHITTICK: I'm here.
And the tour regroups
at the end of August.
And we tech in Denver.
And so the reopening
is in Denver,
and then they're booked
for a few more years.
And I'm also a mother.
So if anybody's a mother or
father, it's a full-time job.
And I'm also doing some
of my own choreography.
So I'm doing a little
production of "South Pacific"
in Cape Cod--
MELISSA BENOIST: Oh, fun.
JOYCE CHITTICK: --coming
up here this summer
at the Cape Playhouse.
So it's a very short stint,
and it rehearses in New York,
so I don't have to
leave "Beautiful."
I can still do my job here.
SPEAKER: Great.
And still have
your side projects?
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yes.
SPEAKER: Great.
Well, thank you again.
JOYCE CHITTICK: I
think we have one.
SPEAKER: Oh, do we
have another question?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
So I have two kids.
My daughter is 15, and my
son is turning 11 tomorrow.
And both of them are religious
"Supergirl" fans, as well as
"Glee," certain
episodes of "Glee" fans.
And my son is an aspiring
song and dance man.
He's a complete musical
theater passionate performer.
And I was curious to the point
about taking classes and making
sure that you're still doing
the work of taking classes.
Knowing that you do
eight shows a week,
what would you say, Melissa, are
the key classes that you keep
up with that you keep taking,
or in terms of really putting
in the training
to be a performer?
MELISSA BENOIST: Well, I don't
have to dance in "Beautiful,"
but if I did, I would for
sure be in ballet and jazz.
Ballet, to me, is
the most important.
JOYCE CHITTICK:
It's the foundation.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
When I was doing eight shows
a week, in my early days,
I would race uptown
between shows
and go take a class at Steps.
And not only that, I would
start with a voice lesson
across the street at
Ansonia for an hour,
and then run next
door to Steps and take
a class for another hour,
and then run back down
to do a show number two.
And I was 20.
I had a lot of
energy to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
And so you just have to keep
doing that instead of sitting
around and dreaming it.
MELISSA BENOIST: This
instrument really is--
it's wild that we do
eight shows a week,
and we rely on these two tiny
little muscles in our throat.
And they're so fragile.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Need
to be maintained.
MELISSA BENOIST: And need to
be maintained and taken care of
and used properly and healthily.
So yeah, voice
lessons are the things
that I still keep up with even
when I'm not doing theater
in Vancouver and in LA.
JOYCE CHITTICK: And if
he's a song and dance man,
he needs to take every
kind of dance class
out there from all
different types of teachers.
MELISSA BENOIST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOYCE CHITTICK: Yeah.
SPEAKER: All right.
Well, thank you again to
Melissa Benoist, Joyce Chittick,
and Stacey Zaloga for joining
us at Google this afternoon.
Everyone visit "Beautiful"
on broadway.com
to buy your tickets and
see Melissa in "Beautiful--
the Carole King
Musical" from now
through August 4th at the
Stephen Sondheim Theater.
Thank you all for joining us.
MELISSA BENOIST:
Thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE]